two and a half weeks since the carolina
panthers cut quarterback cam newton four
weeks since jameis winston became a free
agent both are available so peter as we
play this friday edition of what's more
likely who is more likely to be a free
agent when the nfl
season resumes cam newton or jameis
winston
uh
well do you mean when the regular season
resumes or do you mean
when they get sort of get back to
business
i misread that let's say when the nfl
gets back to business when things are
somewhat normal again which guy is more
likely to still be a free agent
cam newton and it doesn't have anything
to do with his ability it has to do with
the fact that nfl teams
i think most nfl teams
want to
talk to cam newton they want their own
doctors to examine cam newton uh and
they want to see look he has not been
cam newton for a year and a half
you know the last year of two last half
of 2018 and then all of 2019
obviously you know he either wasn't
playing or was a shell of himself
so
this is not the world conspiring against
cam newton
this is what sense would it make to sign
a guy to obviously he's not going to
take one year 4 million i mean you know
what sense does it make to sign this guy
to a big deal when you don't have any
idea
other than these videos
you might have some idea but you don't
really know because your physicians have
not had their hands on them so i think
it's more likely to be cam
at the risk of outsmarting myself in the
way that wallace shawn did while trying
to figure out which goblet of wine had
the iocane powder i'm going to go a
little bit next level here because i
think that before the nfl is back to
normal there's going to be a window some
way somehow for someone to come to a
point of comfort regarding cam newton's
current health and that someone will
pounce on him before it's open season
again and conversely i think jameis
winston is going to need more time to
come to grips with his new reality his
new reality is you ain't a starting
quarterback in the nfl and you're going
to get paid accordingly after making 45
million over five years and i think it's
going to take jameis more time and he
also may be inclined to just sit back
and wait for someone to get injured why
lock in is the backup somewhere when
maybe ben roethlisberger disappears in
week two again or maybe tom brady gets
injured and peter i don't want to put
the jinx on tom brady but i guarantee
you and you're the one who reported what
the buccaneers wish list was brady
bridgewater jameis if brady gets injured
and jamis is available they're calling
jameis
that is
that sounds absolutely ridiculous but
it's not
and
one general no i'm serious i had one
general manager a couple of weeks ago
say if i were if i were those two guys
and if andy dalton gets on the street
and i were them i wouldn't sign with
anybody unless it was new england
but i wouldn't sign with anybody until
training camp started and somebody pulls
a hammy or or
something happens to a starting
quarterback
um because look mike i mean you know
jameis winston knows that it's very
likely he's not going to start at the
start of this season cam newton probably
knows the same thing
and unless it's new england or maybe
jacksonville i'm doing exactly what you
suggest and that is
just you know hold your powder and and
and just
just stay
seated
until you know and just stay in shape
and get ready to play with somebody mike
we already know
this is going to be
it's it's shaping up to be the strangest
year
in history or at least since the
philadelphia eagles and pittsburgh
steelers combined to be the steagles
um you know during world war ii and to
me
if you don't know what's going to happen
okay
mystery is your friend
if you're cam newton or jameis winston
honestly because something weird is
going to happen
in the month of august or september when
teams go back so unless it's new england
or maybe jacksonville i'm not signing at
all
i mean at a very basic level without an
off season program to keep guys in shape
they come back for training camp we may
see more injuries and there may be a
greater likelihood of quarterback
injuries and then boom the phone rings
cam newton jameis winston we have a job
for you right now as the number one guy
on the depth chart all right who is more
likely to end up in the playoffs next
year assuming there is a year in 2020 of
football the buccaneers are the patriots
now that's a really good question um i
think the buccaneers are gonna make the
playoffs if i had to pick it right now
i'd say the bucks
uh because
i keep coming back to this mic
tampa bay was on a four-game winning
streak last year
entering the last two games of the year
and they had two home games against
houston and atlanta
they should have won both
anybody who watched those two games
would have told you they should have won
both but they didn't because jameis
winston threw six interceptions
now it's easy to say well maybe tom
brady wouldn't have had him seven and
seven i i don't know
but i do think that the tampa bay
buccaneers have a very good chance to be
a wild card team this year
and look new england is always going to
be good with bill belichick
but you know with a mystery person at
quarterback
and with still
huge issues at the skill positions
um i i think right now on paper
and again i'm not saying this is about
coaching but i'm saying it's about
talent on the field
i think tampa bay right now the starting
unit right now is better than new
england
yeah and when we look at new england and
say it's bill belichick plus we don't
know who at quarterback and we don't
know how well that guy's gonna perform
at least in tampa bay you've got a
proven commodity in tom brady and a guy
who's a two-time nfl coach of the year
and bruce arians who has shown he knows
a thing or two so there's less
uncertainty with those guys and you're
right last year seven and nine despite
jameis winston throwing 30 interceptions
and they do have the talent at the skill
positions and they're hoping that they
have the improvement defensively i think
the buccaneers are more likely to end up
in the postseason and remember there's
an extra spot per conference this year
so it's going to be a little bit easier
for a team like tampa bay to sneak in
also easier for the patriots to become a
wild card but you know they they haven't
been a wild card at any time during bill
belichick's tenure they've always won
the division they've never gotten in as
a wild card team all right one more
before we break what's more likely the
fact that teams are losing pro days
in-person visits etc will make teams
value them less next year or the fact
that they don't have those devices to
prepare for the draft will make teams
value them more next year
it definitely they'll value them more
next year for a very simple reason
you saw the combine this year and i
wrote my column the other day mike
34 corners
in the combine in 2020
leaving indianapolis
nfl teams had had complete dossiers on
only 10
of the 34 corners two reasons number one
with the workouts being later in the day
and at night a lot of guys you know who
had already spent the day doing
interviews doing all this stuff
a lot of them said i'm just going to run
i'm going to do these drills at my pro
day so a lot of them just didn't do it
and obviously secondarily some of them
coming back from injury
didn't want to do anything until their
pro days so
what is going to happen next year i
believe is that pro days will take on
even more significance because more and
more players judging by 2020 are going
to skip doing stuff at the combine
and one last point i want to reiterate
from yesterday's show when we played a
clip of the brandon bean interview i did
wednesday the bills gm pointed out that
the thing he misses most is the
in-person visits because of the
intelligence they gather on the players
when they're in the back seat of the car
and the person who's driving is
listening to everything and gathering
every tidbit when the person's guard is
down you don't get the access to those
moments when the prospect's guard is
down it makes it harder to crack through
that shell of preparation and get to the
real person before you make your
decisions about who to draft
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports